hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be taking a look at a
much more somber topic than usual the
deaths of some of the late and great
actors that took part in the series in
2022 we lost a couple of the Harry
Potter grades including Robbie Coltrane
Hagrid and Leslie Phillips the Sorting
hand and I thought that with the closing
of the year we could honor the rest of
the names big and small that we've lost
over the decades let's dive in Richard
Harris Dumbledore Richard Harris was an
Irish actor and singer and the first
actor to play Albus Dumbledore Bree
Michael Gambon Harris actually turned
down the role of Dumbledore initially as
he was afraid that it would be all that
he was remembered for remarking I don't
just want to be remembered for being in
those bloody films he went on to appear
in the first two films in the series
Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
and Harry Potter in the Chamber of
Secrets before tragically passing away
from Hodgkin's lymphoma the new
Dumbledore Michael Gambon was cast as
his replacement four months after his
death
and though Harris once remarked that he
didn't want to be remembered for being
in Harry Potter and though he had an
illustrious career that existed outside
of Harry Potter it'll be hard not to
remember his role as the wise old wizard
Robert Knox Marcus belby Robert Knox is
perhaps best known for playing the role
of Marcus belby a Ravenclaw student at
Hogwarts and a fellow member of Slughorn
slug Club knox's death was extremely
tragic as in 2008 the tender age of 18
years old he was killed outside of a
London bar after coming to the aid of
his younger brother Knox only had a
small part in the Half Blood Prince as
Marcus Balby but he was set to repeat
his part in the remaining Harry Potter
movies before his death
Richard Griffiths Vernon dursley Richard
Griffiths is best known for playing the
role of Harry's awful Uncle Vernon
dursley as far as casting goes Griffiths
was one of the best choices that
filmmakers could have made the British
actor who had an illustrious career on
both screen and Stage died in 2013
following complications after heart
surgery Richard was by my side during
two of the most important moments of my
career I was proud to know him said
Daniel Radcliffe Elizabeth Spriggs the
fat lady Elizabeth Spriggs played the
role of the portrait of the fat lady
which guarded the entrance to the
Gryffindor common room to access the
common room Gryffindor students would
have to give her the right password
Spriggs was a longtime actress with the
Royal Shakespeare company and National
Theater she was replaced as the fat lady
by comedian Dawn French in 2004 and
tragically passed away in 2008. Timothy
Bateson creature her though Timothy
Bateson didn't appear on screen his
voice was behind the infernal utterings
of creature the black family house elf
an actor for most of his life Bateson
certainly had an illustrious career
before his death in 2009. after his
death he was replaced by Simon McBurney
who finished up the Harry Potter films
Eric Sykes Frank Bryce Eric Sykes played
muggle Frank Bryce a resident of little
hangleton that did the gardening for the
riddle family he appears in the
beginning of the Goblet of Fire the
Sykes was an English radio stage
television and film writer comedian
actor and director whose performing
career spanned more than 50 years Sykes
died at his home on a summer morning in
2012. Dave legendo Fenway Grayback Dave
legeno played the notorious werewolf
fenrik rayback zudo Death Eater and fair
inspiring symbol in his life legena was
an accomplished actor and athlete
tragically legena died of heat stroke
look at the tender age of 50 while
hiking in California's death valley his
body was found in a remote area and
there was reportedly no foul play
involved Jimmy Gardner Ernie prang Jimmy
Gardner is known for playing Ernie prang
the driver of the double decker night
bus in Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban Gardner was a former member of
the royal Air Force observing during
World War II and made his acting debut
in the 1960s in 2010 Gardner passed away
at the age of 85. Roger Lloyd pack Body
Crouch senior Roger Lloyd pack played
Barty character senior an influential
Ministry of magic official and the
father of party crunch Jr who was played
by David Tennant he is best known for
playing Trigger in Only Fools and Horses
from 1981 to 2003 and Owen knew it in
the Vicar of Dibley from 1994 to 2007.
in 2014 Lloyd pack passed away due to
complications from pancreatic cancer at
the age of 69. Alfred Burke Armando
Depot Alfred Burke played former
Hogwarts Headmaster Armando dipped the
Headmaster in charge before Albus
Dumbledore Alfred Burke was best known
for playing Frank marker in the TV drama
series public eye which ran for over 10
years Burke died at the age of 92 in
2011. Helen McCrory Narcissa Malfoy
actress Helen McCrory played Narcissa
Malfoy in the Harry Potter series wife
of Lucius and mother of Draco however
though she is well known for Harry
Potter she also had a great deal of
success outside of the series playing
the role of poly gray in the popular
series peaky blinders in 2021 McCrory
tragically passed away at the age of 52
after fighting breast cancer her husband
Damien Lewis stated that she had died
peacefully at home surrounded by a wave
of love from friends and family Hazel
Douglas Matilda bagshot Hazel Douglas
played batilde bagshot great aunt of
Gaelic Grindelwald magical historian and
author of A History of Magic she also
played nagini disguised as Patel the bag
shot despite securing the Harry Potter
role well into her 80s Hazel's acting
credits stretched back to the early days
of Television she died in 2016 at the
age of 92.
Peter can't write a fire stage Peter
Cartwright played elfia's Doge in Harry
Potter and the Order of the Phoenix the
role was later Taken on by actor David
rile Cartwright was a South african-born
British actor who made hundreds of
appearances in television film and on
radio and worked extensively in the
theater both in the provinces and
London's West End Cartwright died in
2013 at the age of 78. David rile
alphia's Doge as mentioned above David
rile took on the role of alphaist Doge
after Peter cart writes performance in
the Order of the Phoenix Ryle was an
English stage film and television
character actor known for his leading
roles in litton's diary and goodnight
sweetheart as well as memorable roles in
Dennis Potters the singing detective and
Andrew Davies adaptation of to play the
king Ryle passed away on Christmas day
in 2014. four years after his role in
the last Harry Potter film Derek dead
Tom from The Leaky cauldron Derek
Deadman played Tom the landlord in
keeper and Barman of the Leaky cauldron
in Harry Potter and the Philosopher's
Stone he was later replaced by Jim
tavare who had a completely different
look in Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban over his 38-year career as an
actor Deadman appeared in numerous
British television shows and films in
2014 he died at the age of 74 from
diabetes complications Alan Rickman
Severus Snape Alan Rickman expertly
played the role of Professor Severus
Snape the sarcastic and cold anti-hero
that ended up being a fan favorite known
for his deep languid voice Rickman
trained at the Royal Academy of dramatic
art in London and became a member of the
royal Shakespeare company he had a long
and illustrious career with many notable
roles in 2016 Rickman tragically passed
after being diagnosed with terminal
cancer a diagnosis says that he kept
private I think it's fair to say that
Alan Rickman will remain in the hearts
of fans always Terence Baylor the Bloody
Baron Terence Baylor played the Bloody
Baron the Slytherin house ghost at
Hogwarts Baylor was a New Zealand film
television and Stage actor whose most
memorable roles were Monty Python's Life
of Brian and Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone in 2016 Baylor
passed away at the age of 86. bullwitter
Eldred warpool bullwitter played Eldred
warpool a wizard in writer who was once
a favorite student of Horus Slughorn
Ritter had a long and illustrious acting
career in both film and television
appearing in films such as Quantum of
Solace the eagle and operation mincemeat
Britta tragically passed away from a
brain tumor in 2021 John heard Garrick
olivander perhaps one of the best known
actors in this list Don hurt played the
role of Garrick olivander proprietor of
olivander's one shop and the first man
to give Harry Potter himself a wand
hurt was an actor for five decades and
played many celebrated roles in films
such as 1984 dogville the naked civil
servant and the Elephant Man hurt passed
away in 2017 at the age of 77. Sam
Beasley Professor everard actor Sam
Beasley played the role of Professor
everard one of Hogwarts most celebrated
Headmasters Beasley was encouraged to
become a professional actor in the 1930s
as a teenager by his mother and ended up
having an incredibly long and
illustrious career until he died in 2017
at the age of 101 Robert Hardy Cornelius
fudge Robert Hardy played the role of
Cornelius fudge the ever frustrating
minister of magic that infamously denied
the Resurgence of Lord Voldemort Hardy
had an incredibly impressive and long
career in theater film and television he
passed away in 2017 at the age of 91.
Vern try wire grip hook Vern Troyer
first played the role of grip hook a
goblin who worked at Gringotts Wizarding
Bank in Diagon Alley before being
replaced by Warwick Davis Joya is
perhaps best known for his role as Mini
Me and the Austin Powers films in 2018
Dreyer passed at the age of 49. Robbie
Coltrane rubius Hagrid Robbie Coltrane
played the role of rubius Hagrid lovable
half Giant and Hogwarts keeper of keys
and grounds Coltrane died just recently
toward the end of 2022 at the age of 72.
Coltrane had a long and impressive
acting career and his most recent
appearance on camera was during the 20th
Harry Potter anniversary special
returned to Hogwarts with this one being
so recent it stings a little bit more
Leslie Phillips the sorting out Leslie
Phillips iconically voiced the Sorting
ads the magic hat and Hogwarts staple
the design students to Hogwarts houses
during the Sorting ceremony Phillips had
a long and illustrious career featuring
in over 200 movies TV series and radio
shows collectively he's particularly
well known for his role in the carry on
franchise in the late 50s he died
peacefully in his sleep at the age of 98
and that's it for today who was your
favorite actor in the Harry Potter
series leave a comment down below and as
always if you enjoy the content please
be sure to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
to the well-organized Mind death is by
the next great adventure
foreign